hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Ursula kala greens short story the ones
who walk away from OMA lost has been
anthologized not only in many science
fiction collections but also within
textbooks and collections that have to
do with ethics and the reason is because
she's formulating for us in in a sort of
narrative way a sort of paradox and
thought experiment with several
reflections quite important ones about
the nature of human happiness and a
query for us that she doesn't actually
ask in the story but just leaves for us
to ask an answer on our own namely if we
were residents of this city of Omaha
would we stay or would we go would we be
among those who walk away or would we be
those who find ourselves able to accept
what she describes as a sort of bargain
or rule or pact a requirement and the
story is divided up into three main
parts each of which corresponds to some
that she wants us to think about
something that she proposes to us and
she uses her great powers of narration
and storytelling to do so so the first
part has to do with the happiness of the
City of Omaha and I'm gonna skip through
some of the introductory material
because we're mostly interested in the
the ethical content here the nature of
human happiness she says that this is a
city in which the citizens or residents
are actually quite happy she says joyous
how is one to tell about joy how to
describe the citizens of Omaha
she says they're not simple people
although they were happy and she thinks
that considering these matters is
important for us in our late modern
times because we've actually got some
mixed up ideas about happiness she says
that we tend to make certain assumptions
so one of the first things that she
tells us has to do with the you might
say political organization of this city
she says there was no king they did not
use swords or keep slaves I do not know
the rules and laws of their society but
I suspect they were singularly few so
the norms governing them are relatively
manageable you could say as they did she
says without monarchy and slavery so
they also got on without the stock
exchange the advertisement the secret
police and the bomb so it sounds like
these are people who are living a
simpler life and and this would actually
make good sense given the fact that you
know Ursula K Le Guin has noted at many
different points that the political
ideology or theory that she comes
closest to is that of anarchism
and in this case it's not anarchism
though there actually is a structure to
this society she tells us that I'm going
to jump ahead to technology they they
might not have cars or helicopters in
and above the streets and she says this
follows from the
that the people of Omaha are a happy
people but she tells us and here's one
of the early lessons about the nature of
happiness happiness these are her words
is based on a just discrimination of
what is necessary what is neither
necessary nor destructive and what is
destructive and she says in this middle
category that of what is neither
necessary nor destructive that of
comfort luxury exuberance they could
perfectly well have things like central
heating subway trains washing machines
and all sorts of marvelous devices not
yet invented here like floating light
sources or feuless power or a cure for
the common cold and then she says or
they could have none of that it doesn't
matter the level of Technology is not
what's making them happy this is not a
you could say technological or
technocratic utopia instead it has to do
with a different sort of condition so
backing up a little bit she talks about
these people being no less complex than
us and here's another lesson that she
has about the nature of happiness she
says that we have a bad habit encouraged
by pedants and sophisticates of
considering happiness as something
rather stupid we think that people are
happy when their simple needs are met
and we say things like ignorance is
bliss and we suggest that if you just
find your own little as Voltaire said
your own little garden then you'll be
okay and she says no no that is not the
kind of people that we're talking about
in this city she says that the the
problem is that we think that only pain
is intellectual only evil interesting
and she calls this the treason of the
artist a refusal to admit the banality
of evil and the terrible boredom of pain
if you can't lick him join him if it
hurts repeat it and then she says we're
you know making a choice here to praise
the spares to condemn delight to embrace
violence as Toulouse hole
of everything else we can no longer
describe a happy man or make any
celebration of joy so how can I tell you
about the people of Omaha
she says they were mature intelligent
passionate adults whose lives were not
wretched and she's willing to say yes
this is kind of a miracle if you think
about how screwed up the world is at the
time that she's writing it and the time
she's lived through at the time that
we're living in right now and how
fleeting what we think to be happiness
often turns out to be perhaps she's
right about that so she says let's
imagine this city so so we've already
put aside the issue of technology what
would they have and she says here we go
it might strike you as kind of
goody-goody smiles bells parades horses
blare as she says if so and an orgy if
an orgy would help don't hesitate but
let's not have any temples where orgies
are taking place with priests and
priestesses devoted to that as a matter
of fact let's have religion but no
clergy if that's one thing that you need
in order to imagine a beautiful
wonderful place where people are happy
some sort of post sexual revolution you
know on klav go ahead and imagine that
she says then she says one thing that I
know there is none of anomie loss is
guilt that's the one key thing that's
missing then she goes on and she says
what about drugs or intoxicants and so
she imagines in intoxicants that she
calls Druze it will perfume the waves of
the city it brings a great lightness and
brilliance to the mind and limbs and
then after some hours of dreamy languor
and wonderful visions at last the very
Arcana in most secrets of the universe
as well as exciting the pleasure of sex
beyond belief
and it's not habit-forming so imagine
the the best drug without any of the bad
consequences or side effects that we
attribute to drugs and let these people
have that as well that's sort of
enjoyment
she says for those who don't really want
that then there's beer yeah that's quite
good as well what else is there she says
that's all good stuff
that's to help you imagine it here's
what I want to put on the table myself
that they would really have and if
you've ever experienced or at least seen
from a distance something like this or
imagined it this is the really key thing
about why this city is so wonderful
there is what he calls a celebration of
courage
she says the sense of victory the
celebration of courage but as we did
without clergy let us do without
soldiers a boundless and generous
contentment a magnanimous
triumph felt not against some outer
enemy but in communion with the finest
and fairest and the souls of all men
everywhere and the splendor of the
world's summer this is what swells the
hearts of the people of all my loss the
victory they celebrate is that of life
we might think here at this point of the
dictum in ancient philosophy that
nothing human is foreign to me
nothing is alien to me what's the best
in humanity is things that we can
celebrate whether it came from our
nation our city or from somewhere else
now she says okay this does seem rather
utopian you may have a hard time
imagining this let's add the second
element and here we come to the part
that induces a sort of sadness as we
read it at a certain age she says every
citizen of Omaha becomes aware of a
terrible reality what is this reality so
I'll read it to you she's describing it
in the basement under one of the
beautiful public buildings of Omaha
store perhaps in the cellar of one of
its spacious private homes there is a
room it has one locked door and no
window there is a couple of mops with
stiff clotted foul-smelling hands stand
near
the bucket the floor is dirt the room is
about three paces long and too wide it's
actually a mere broom closet in the room
here's the key element a child is
sitting it could be a boy or a girl it
looks about six but is actually nearly
10 it is feeble-minded perhaps it was
born defective or perhaps it has become
imbecile through fear malnutrition and
neglect it picks its nose and
occasionally fumbles vaguely with its
toes and its genitals
it sits hunched in the corner farthest
from the bucket and the two mops it is
afraid of the moths it finds them
horrible it's just its eyes but it knows
the mops are still standing there and
the door is locked
nobody will come the door is always
locked and nobody ever comes except that
sometimes because the child has no
understanding of time or interval
sometimes the door rattles terribly and
opens and a person or several people are
there one may come in and kick the child
to make it stand up the others never
come close but peer at in at it with
frightened disgusted eyes the fool bowl
and water jug are hastily filled the
door is locked the eyes disappear the
people at the door never say anything
but the child who has not always lived
in the tool room and can remember
sunlight and its mother's voice
sometimes speaks I will be good it says
please let me out I will be good they
never answer the child used to scream
for help at night and cry a good deal
but now it only makes a kind of whining
and it speaks less and less often it is
so thin there are no calves to its legs
its belly protrudes it lives on a half
bowl of cornmeal and grease today it is
naked its buttocks and thighs are a
massive festered sores as it sits in its
own excrement continually so we have
this picture of a terribly abused child
in the household or in the public
building of Omaha somewhere and now
here's where the the decision comes in
she tells us that all the people of
Omaha know that it's there some have
come to see it others merely know that
it's there
she tells us also some of them
understand why some do not but they all
understand that there's a correlation
between the happiness and beauty of the
city and then a whole bunch of other
things that we'll talk about in a moment
and this child as she calls it
abominable misery now it's not just the
totality of the city and its happiness
that we're talking about all of the
individual relations of happiness as
well are dependent on this she says the
tenderness of their friendships the
health of their children the wisdom of
their scholars the skill of their makers
even the abundance of their harvest and
kindly weather's of their skies all of
these depend on this child's misery and
you could say continued abuse so as she
says this is this is a coming-of-age
ceremony in a way between eight and
twelve years old this fact about their
existence is explained to children
whenever they seem capable of
understanding and most of those who go
to look at the child are in fact
themselves children now they they
understand this on a cognitive level
they also understand this on an
effective feeling level she tells us
that they feel disgust which they
thought they were superior to they're
shocked and sickened at the sight so we
have that entire modality of aversion
over here then there's also anger
outrage impotence they feel all of those
at the same time they also feel pity or
compassion
she says they would like to do something
for the child but they cannot why she
says that if this child were comforted
and cleaned and taken out that would
indeed be a very good thing you would be
creating new good in the world but the
beauty the prosperity the happiness of
OMA lost and its people would be
shattered at that instance and that she
says those are the terms to exchange all
the goodness and grace of every life and
for that single small improvement to
throw away the happiness of thousands
for the chance of the happiness of one
that would indeed be to let guilt within
the walls and she says these terms are
strict and absolute you may not even
speak a word to the child so what
happens
she says the young people often go home
in tears they are affected by it on a
feeling level she talks about this as
being a paradox but then eventually
nearly everybody comes to terms with it
they look at the great good of the city
that they're enjoying and they say well
the misery of one is opposed to the
happiness of thousands they in effect
carry out a sort of utilitarian
calculation and they say this is indeed
bad but I can live with it given the
great good that is being generated they
also realize that even if you took the
child out and did clean it and comfort
it and tried to teach it and help it in
its way on its development whatever
happiness that child would be able to
enjoy and it may not be able to enjoy
any would be of a very low quality so it
for most people according to the green
in this city they're able to come to
terms with it they know it's always
there but they still remain happy as a
result here's where we come to the third
thing and the reason for the title of
this work she says well you read you the
passage at times one of the adolescent
girls or boys who go to see the child
does not go home to weep or rage does
not in fact go home at all sometimes
also a man or woman much older falls
silent for a day or two and then leaves
home these people go out into the street
and walk down the street alone they keep
walking and walk straight out of the
city of home loss through the beautiful
gates they keep walking across the
farmlands of Omaha
each one goes alone youth their girl man
or woman night falls the traveler must
pass down
streets between the houses with yellow
windows and on out into the darkness of
the fields each alone they go western
north towards the mountains they go on
they leave alma las they walk ahead into
the darkness and they do not come back
the place they go to is a place even
less imaginable to most of us than the
city of happiness I cannot describe it
at all it is possible that it does not
exist but they seem to know where they
are going the ones who walk away from
Omelas
we don't need to know where they're
going we know that they are rejecting
this bargain this pact these terms that
predicate the happiness of many on the
suffering of one they are rejecting it
so there's something negative about it
but the way that the green is describing
it there's also something positive they
know where they're going they know
something other than this choice and
they are choosing instead another way so
the question then that of course that
this frames for us is not just is this
okay or could something like this exist
but what would you do would you be one
of the ones who would walk away from
home loss I think many of us would like
to think of ourselves that way but if
you really sat there and you you read
the descriptions provided and you think
about this and you understand that
generations after generations after
generations have made this bargain and
have been okay with it indeed lived a
happy life well it might not be so easy
in real practice for you to do this so
Liguilla here has framed a very
interesting thought experiment in great
narrative form that she invites all of
us to consider
you